in September 2015 deer deck married his
longtime girlfriend Brianna Flores the
two got engaged at Disneyland Resorts in
April 2015. after enjoying a romantic
and extravagant baby moon in Bora Bora
the couple welcomed their first child on
September 9 2016. a son named Coda
according to E news
deer deck and Flores seem to be quite
happy with Parenthood and in December
2017 the couple announced the arrival of
their second child a baby girl named
Nala overall it seems deer deck has
allowed himself to fade out of the
Spotlight by choice although he has fun
on the set of ridiculousness he isn't
looking to be the star of the show
anymore he'd rather be the guy pulling
the levers behind the curtain aside from
hosting Ridiculousness Dyrdek says his
true passion is for entrepreneurship so
he could also be the genius behind some
of your new favorite Brands and products
nowadays he seems to be doing a little
bit of everything and he's loving it